hi I'm Steve Carell I'm in LA shooting
the cover of GQ Man of the Year issue
right yeah if I were to nominate the man
of the year that person would be the
pulp
you know what skinny jeans are out but
he looks he still looks fantastic enter
my wife Nancy I would nominate this
woman of the year I'm married up with my
wife she is better looking she is
smarter and she's funnier than I am
and again skinny jeans she looks good my
song of the year was all about the bass
not being facetious
I like the song I can see you behind the
camera actually I see less at this
funniest person this year Wow boy Will
Ferrell is always funny Zach
Galifianakis Kristen Wiig Tina Fey I
don't know I have a lot of very funny
friends I'm lucky and it makes me feel
so badly about myself because they're
all better I would say my movie of the
years rosewater directed by Jon Stewart
not a good person but excellent director
I started to watch things like Deadliest
Catch
it's about crab fishing in Alaska I was
asked the question how long would I last
on an Alaskan crab fishing boat
if i toughed it out if I really really
tried my best 45 minutes tops something
I'd like to do next year getting into
cycling again I hope that if I am next
year's man of the year that my thighs
will be enormous and that the photo
shoot will just emphasize my newly found
enormous thighs if you could make jeans
into a thong that's what I would wear if
I could sum up 2014 one word it would be
doable Isha's sign it sign it off to the
people because they won't know it's over
until we say goodbye okay because you
could just stop and then people will
drift away the show just ends and then
people going to the kitchen and get
something to eat but I'll give you some
sort of thanks for watching that's good